estamos en lo que se conoce como el
corazón de esa que al frente está la
catedral y detrás están algunos de los
edificios más emblemáticos y a pesar de
todas las amenazas contra esta ciudad la
tercera más importante del país y una de
las más importantes desde el punto de
vista estratégico por el puerto por su
salida al mar negro porque aquí están
todas las exportaciones especialmente de
trigo que abastecen a europa también
tiene un gran significado histórico no
solamente para los ucranianos sino para
los rusos esto ha llevado a que miles de
personas hayan abandonado la ciudad en
los últimos días especialmente madres y
niños pero podemos ver que todavía sigue
habiendo bastante vida todavía hay niños
jugando los parques todavía hay mascotas
y hay gente que se niega a irse de la
ciudad a pesar de las amenazas dicen que
hasta hace unos pocos días había 11
navíos parqueados en el mar frente a las
costas de odessa pero las condiciones
climatológicas han llevado a que
volvieran a al puerto de crimea dicen
que este es el marzo más frío de
muchísimos años y este puede haber
jugado en beneficio de la defensa de
este puerto que sea más adorado por los
rusos aquí vienen millones de rusos cada
año a veranear